yeah I've been on some crazy road trips
we did this project a few years ago
where we went through all 48 states in
12 days and then one of the filmmakers
bounced to Alaska and Hawaii but yeah we
you know it's just the hustle of driving
verse shooting and make sure you have
that rotation get enough sleep I always
have this you know rule about driving
and sleep it's sort of like if I feel
like you know if I feel feel that
feeling of going out then that's the
time to pull over and sleep so because
it's always worth it to survive here
right but yeah with gear I think it's
always like a security issue cuz your
gear especially like your shot footage
your hard drives or whatever your media
is on is its valuable you can't you
can't ever leave it so it's always like
on your back it's always like brought in
with you if you go in to eat it's always
you know you're not leaving in the car
locked up because I've definitely had
gear stolen from locked cars I have
friends that have had their entire movie
go down because all the cameras were
taking it so you know it's always with
you you know it's like like your wallet
or something so what about protecting it
from the elements to suppose you're
driving and it's Arizona in the summer
what where's the gear and what are you
protecting it yeah I mean well I think
nowadays gears made to be weather
resistant to be kind of waterproof to be
like it's just amazing the resilience of
today's gear so it's almost like you
just worry about getting what you want
almost and have your backups but your
lens can be fixed you can buy a new lens
you kind of it's a balance of like well
are you going to risk the gear or you're
going to get the shot and in today's
world where you can like rent lens is
this is the fascinating world now where
you can just rent your gear for thirty
dollars a day it's it's amazing it's an
amazing time but yeah you definitely
want to keep keep gear protected and
cleaned and dust free and
it's get it gets difficult sometimes and
then how do you keep it dust free not
not necessarily while shooting but like
when it's packed up what's your way of
dealing we have compressed air
compressed air and baby wipes for for
stuff for like your lenses or uh you
know lens cleaner oh uh huh lens cleaner
and lens paper and stuff like that okay
you